well Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says the war will continue and
Hamas members will be hounded no matter
where they are he was speaking during a
visit to a military intelligence
unit we have fighters on the ground
sometimes also underground and we have
eyes in the sky we say to the Hamas
terrorists we see you and we will get
you we are continuing the war deepening
the fighting in the southern Gaza Strip
and elsewhere and we are fighting until
the end and with the help of the most
advanced
technology okay let's get the latest now
from hamda Salute who joins me from
occupied East Jerusalem and we have some
developing news understand there are
more raids happening in the occupied
West Bank what exactly are you
hearing continuous raids into the early
morning hours of the occupied West Bank
clashes still ongoing in several places
like Bethlehem hibron tubas and
where we have seen the largest of the
Israeli military raids this evening a
drone strike on the N refugee camp
killing six Palestinians and wounding
others some of them critically the
Palestinian red cren says that the
Israeli occupation forces prevented
ambulances and other medical staff from
reaching the injured and the Dead video
footage shared by those locals on social
media shows is Israeli military vehicles
blocking the ambulances in the street
locals are also saying that Israeli
snipers are positioned on several
different roofs of the building as they
are continuously raiding homes looking
to arrest wanted Palestinian Fighters
Fierce clashes still ongoing at this
hour this is just a continuation of the
intensified Israeli raids that have been
happening since October the 7th while
the near nightly raids have been going
on for almost two years the Israeli Army
has really upped them since the start of
the war you're looking at 311
Palestinians who've been killed in the
occupied West Bank since the War Began
and additionally around 5,000 arrests
thanks so much for that update that's H
salute for us in the occupied East
Jerusalem